that's the new girl it's her first day
some people say there'll be trouble
some people saw trouble coming right
from the start one is right to rush the
alarm kept low turn good office
management begins at home you're late
guilty sir you'd better hurry my
coffee's probably getting cold I wonder
I love to get up in the morning I've got
such a nice boss to look forward to
incidentally did you see the urgent note
I left on your pad last night top policy
meeting at 9:15 yes sir Dennis got back
from Washington late yesterday and he
called the meeting after you're gone
Thanks this must be the new government
contract was there any explanation I
tried to finesse some information from
his secretary Beth
but Jesus informative as a quiz program
okay I better get going have some hot
coffee waiting for me sir good office
management begins at home they'll quit
first one then another whatever they do
they're gonna make hell for that first
Negro girl you put on the payroll look
mark we're not walking into this
blindfolded now Todd doesn't pay me to
manage personnel so that personnel can
run the plant the way it wants what does
that mean that you're going to sit
behind every secretary with a gun in her
back it means we can put this new policy
through without trouble now of course
we'll have to move slowly at first no
matter how badly we need them now you've
said it
we need them gentlemen
the Negro represents a labor force that
hasn't even begun to be tabbed how about
a Kurt your departments been crying for
help think we can make it work maybe
works on the shop Negro and white hands
work side by side we don't have any
trouble well how was it when you started
not bad there was a lot of talk about
trouble but the union was on our side
that time they called a meeting and by
the time they were through there wasn't
any opposition those were men Kurt they
worked with their hands how about women
women are different I think we're asking
for trouble
just what is we are afraid of bad
publicity money or we may be raising
problems to hide our own prejudices look
Lyle I don't think I'm a bigot Lyle
didn't say that mark and I don't think
I'm a man of prejudices at least not any
that I'd let it interfere with profits
my department has sales I'm mostly on
the outside and a man I sell the product
who doesn't care what color the girl is
who types up the bill so because I'm on
the outside I get around I hear stories
Cara stories strike slowdowns trouble
that's all let's call it morale a lot of
white girls just don't want to work next
to a Negro girl whether you like it or
not well now I'll tell you something I'm
not running for election and I'm not
going to run scared
no twenty-year-old stenographer is going
to tell me how to run my business I've
just come back from Washington I met
there with the President's Committee on
government contracts believe me it was
no tea party between me and the
committee they were talking business
since when is the president's committee
running Dennis industries we're not
talking just about Dennis industries
when we talk about this we're talking
national policy and it's not no we've
had it ever since World War two under
the president's directive no company can
deal with the government can get a
contract unless its policies are clearly
non-discriminatory although we employ
Negroes on the production line that's
not enough as long as we set up a color
line at the front door of the officers
or any line for that matter we are
discriminating aren't we also
responsible to the stockholders we can't
afford we can afford anything our
competition can if we can't we don't
belong in business
from this meeting on our policy will be
to hire every person we need strictly
according to ability if you want to set
an example put the first Negro secretary
in my office nope not on your life Todd
and have 12 girls quit because we're
giving away one of the most worked for
jobs in the organization now that would
be discrimination just the same I feel
sorry for the first girl you hire she'd
better be strong you're right Kirk she's
got to be hand-picked she's got to be so
likeable that any white girl with a chip
on her shoulder will think twice before
she starts any trouble and so efficient
but any man she works for Oh consider
himself lucky you know I think the
announcement of policy ought to come
from your office Todd not just from
personnel we want every single person in
this outfit to know that you're behind
it down to the last typist in the pool
every girl working here she'd be made to
feel that she's involved in putting
through this new policy right that it
that's about it I'll go with a new
policy
so what are you going to do they've got
to live to lose if they don't take it
easy you two it hasn't even happened yet
I tell you I I know it for a fact I got
it on the best authority right from the
horse's mouth what go ahead laughs maybe
you won't think it's so funny when one
of them is sitting at the desk next to
you or at your desk maybe thought I
wouldn't wish on anybody
ah what's the joke no joke the voice of
doom here spreading your usual morning
cheer yes and this morning she's
colorblind very she's got some very
confidential information on the best of
Thor I tell you it's going to happen
it's done it is overall going to lose
our job so loud I happen to need my time
me I'll quit first well what would we do
without you Oh probably invite my
replacement down here much what's he
talking about
you know Ella she claims they're going
to start hiring some Negro office Oh
around here so what so if I do I quit
you're kidding
go ahead kid you tell him me they love
us you don't mean that I do I always
understand me I haven't got anything
against take Ned the guard at the door
for instance we're good friends and I
like him
that doesn't mean that I want him or his
sister working in the office with me
girls I don't bother them and they don't
bother me that's the way I mean to keep
it where are you working now Mary lanes
at least I was this morning I might not
be this afternoon if I don't get back
pretty soon
Mr Graham should be free in a minute he
told you what he wants to talk to you
about all I know is he said how would I
really like to go to work and could I
drop around to the Urban League on my
lunch hour have you any idea what these
books away please miss Thompson I'm
sorry I kept you waiting
would you come inside you'll only take a
few minutes
good luck Thanks as Miss Thompson and
filling your head full of tall tales
would you have a seat please
cigarette let's see you've been working
in lanes since you got out of high
school right
and now you've graduated from
secretarial school must be pretty rough
working during the day and going to
school at night didn't it I think it was
a little hard on my family than on me
they had to listen to my complaining
well it looks like it might have been
worthwhile how would you like to go to
work as a secretary at Dennis industries
you want the truth don't you mr. Graham
Oh certainly I'd give an eyetooth to
work as a secretary but at Dennis
industries I'm not so sure oh you're
afraid maybe you're not quite good
enough yet huh
no that isn't the reason I'm more afraid
they wouldn't want me at Dennis well
someone does they called me I didn't
call them mr. Graham we're not talking
about anything that's secret they've
never hired a Negro girl everyone knows
that it's not that they discriminate
it's just that they don't hire us maybe
things are changing Mary don't
misunderstand
well I'd love to work at Dennis I do
want a job as a secretary and I could
handle it I know you could I checked
your records you have every
qualification you need now let me bring
you up to date last week the personnel
department of Dennis got in touch with
every employment agency in town it told
them the beginning immediately Negroes
were to be hired on the Dennis Office
force really yes really they also call
up the Urban League and asked us to help
them over the hurdal sounds
serious they are serious they've already
started to map a long-term educational
plan so that the schools around here
will know exactly what kind of help they
need whether they've approached every
organization in town
and asked for their assistance this
could be a tremendous step forward
but what about me suppose I do go up for
the job the personnel department can't
make people like me they can't tell the
other girls that well that that you're
as good as they are no they can't but
they can give you every chance to show
you are very right now they need us and
we certainly need them if we don't take
the chance when it comes along it may
not come along again we have everything
to gain you have everything to gain and
nothing to lose except a job and about
ten feet of pride it's a funny thing
Mary once someone offers you a choice
you can't ever go back to the way it was
before if you don't try when you go out
of here you'll find your pride has
shrunk to ten inches if you do try well
if you do try you may have something to
be really proud of
what do you say
all right I'll try good girl well how's
the crusade for freedom that Dennis
industries coming was a girl coming over
from the Urban League tomorrow morning
but she's through with personnel I'd
like you to have a talk with her
sure lime I'll be glad to have a talk
with you no talk isn't enough in a
situation like this will you mean you
people upstairs are really serious about
this let me point out one thing you will
Dennis Industries does a lot of business
with the government fine and we turn out
a good product and the law says Fair
Employment Practice it never fails up on
cloud 19 the VIPs decide to work a
miracle and then the little wheels
downstairs have to start grinding are
you guests hiring Negro that's not what
I said ly Oh what did you say but I'm
only an office manager I can't make a
hero out of Todd dinner nobody asked you
to do that all you have to do is to
follow company parlance and lose half
the girls in the office while I'm doing
it have you lost any yet not yet but
there's muttering I heard one of the
girls say she'll quit as soon as we hire
a Negro for your information she happens
to be the most popular girl in the
office if she quits it could start an
exodus that would make the one out of
Egypt look like a quiet Sunday afternoon
if she decides to quit I'd like to know
immediately anyone else for that matter
well I tell you it won't work the girls
won't stand for it
okay will you tell me what oh come on
come on don't be naive you know the
reasons as well as I do what the
washrooms for instance you know what I
mean what are these same girls do when
they go to the restaurants in the movie
just supper so they have no choice they
won't have a choice here from now on
no it will we've notified the unions and
asked for the cooperation no trouble
there every department head has made it
official all the way down the line
there's a memo out in black and white so
that everybody can see it and we agreed
that the best way is to make a definite
stand from the top down what you think
we're living in the dark ages we're not
good people going to realize that this
is the 20th century in the United States
of America with freedom and
liberty for all yeah exactly that
doesn't say anything about working where
you don't want to are you telling me you
want to quit well I probably won't have
to my job will just disappear into thin
air along with the rest of the staff you
know I don't understand you well I've
talked to every man in a responsible
position here at Dennis most of them
wonder what all the fuss is about if you
admit they don't like the idea of a
Negro secretary but they're willing to
go along with the idea now go ahead try
them but you you just you keep on saying
it won't work I wonder if you know how
you really feel well I'll tell you you
know those signs you put up in the plant
equal economic opportunity where you can
wallpaper the whole building with them
but you can't change the facts of life
I've got to get home
time isn't well if this girl tomorrow
morning passes all those tests it's your
job to place her in one of those
openings you've been complaining about
for so long
see you later we're very lucky to find
someone with your qualifications miss
Newton thank you
you pass those tests with flying colors
as a matter of fact I thought I'd be too
nervous to hold a pencil all that's left
is a physical just routine I'll have my
secretary fix an appointment with the
medical office kid would you just alert
the medical office that Miss Newton will
be down in about half an hour and now
you'd better meet the man you'll
probably be working for mr. Nelson may I
ask you a question would it be possible
for me to have an assignment in the
accounting department why well to tell
the truth there's a girl in there from
my class at high school we're not
friends exactly but I thought it might
make things miss Newton is a new
employee at Dennis I think you ought to
know our rules we don't give favors we
don't give preferential treatment I'm
sorry I just thought we stick to our
word every employee is treated solely on
his merits for better
oh I see now I'll take you down and
introduce you to mr. Harden so they can
you have to wait the time say right by
you the gentleman who's been complaining
about the lack of office help you don't
get someone to sit at that desk pretty
soon you'll have to dig me out from all
this paperwork I have somebody for you
right now
you better have four hands she's 22
graduate from secretarial school honors
student conscientious loyal eager to
work go on I don't believe him she's
outside would you like to meet her sure
bring her in until her have a pencil
sham so that we can good start
Miss Mary Newton mr. Curt Hardin I think
you'll find your work cut out for you
how do you doing how are you doing
you should have seen his face he just
looked at me like he couldn't believe it
like he couldn't believe it
What did he say he said how do you do he
said it twice and then he turned around
went back to his desk said he'd see me
tomorrow what did the other guy do then
mr. Nelson yeah
smiled like there was some sort of a
joke and then he took me down to the
medical office did anybody say anything
about you being the first coloured girl
in the office they didn't have to you
could see it in their faces the way the
girl in mr. Nelson's office looked at me
maybe you just imagined all of it well
that's a crazy thing to say mama
why should she imagine it it's the truth
you just don't understand
yes I understand you may not think I
understand what I do you think I can't
understand because I'm your mother and
I'm older but but I do
what you're going through isn't new when
I was a young girl I I had to leave high
school to get a job I would have given
anything to work in a shop but it just
wasn't done where I lived nobody ever
heard of a [ __ ] working in a shop
where white girls and white women came
in to buy things so I I got a job
cleaning house and I cleaned house and
cried at nights until I got married
maybe my mother had something she wanted
very bad and couldn't have him cried
about all night I don't know but now I
have you children and I've watched you
grow up and finish school and now Mary's
working in a shop and crying her eyes
out because she can't work in an office
well maybe she can work in an office and
if she can I don't want to see a thrown
away the chance because she's afraid
maybe those people hate up maybe some of
them do and maybe she's imagining a lot
of it dreaming up trouble to hide her
fears and if this is the way it is then
she's got to find out and the only way
to find out is to go to work tomorrow or
else
when she has her own kids she's going to
have to watch him get hurt and crying
and be afraid and she always wondered if
she couldn't have suffered it for them
and maybe made their lives a little
easier the way I sometimes wonder now
money
mr. Nelson
yes I'm resigning serious seriously okay
I appreciate your getting here on time
to tell me you know exactly why I'm
quitting I think you may receive a
personal invitation from mr. Todd Dennis
of Dennis industries to present your
case to him personally but it should
come to this tell him I'd like to see
her right away let's squash this and get
Lyle Ross on the phone Oh Beth may I ask
you a personal question of course where
do you stand on all this you've heard
the policy discussion how do you feel
well honestly mr. Dennis
I wonder where everybody's been I mean
doesn't anybody in this company read the
newspapers or go to the movies I think
it's about time we woke up you can be a
great help to us right now
how by giving the new girl a chance by
making sure that she gets a chance you
mean by being especially nice to her not
especially nice just plain ordinarily
nice common garden-variety knives you
have a certain amount of prestige here
use it well I wouldn't want the other
girls to think I was doing it just
because I was the daughter don't you
start being frightened to think about it
it's not an order just a random comment
on humanity
I'm sorry you want to leave this right
up to now you've been an asset to the
company I'm sorry to mr. Denis up to now
I've enjoyed working here I suppose
you'll be looking for another job
in a plant that doesn't hire Negroes of
course in a plant that doesn't hire them
to work in the office with me well
that's going to be more and more
difficult I think you understand my
position I know your position I don't
understand it it's not difficult to
explain I know I've heard it all before
surely you don't expect us to adjust our
policies to meet your approval frankly
I'd rather not work to work under your
new policy rather not work
well you're lucky how do you mean lucky
you can afford that alternative I can't
afford it neither can most of the people
working here mr. Dennis I just don't
understand why my leaving has suddenly
taken on such importance I wish I felt
flattered by all the tension but I'm
afraid I don't
well the fact is you're leaving the
company is much more important than a
personal matter for me or for you I'm
not going to even attempt to argue with
your prejudices I know that in a few
minutes here I can't change whatever has
made you think the way you've been
thinking for a lifetime but if you don't
mind I'd like to put the shoe on the
other foot you're a popular girl here
probably with good reason what you do
quitting that is they set an example for
a lot of other girls who can't afford
your independence I'm responsible for
this company
that means I'm responsible to the
stockholders for the people working here
to myself even to the whole country
indirectly and it's too late to crawl
back into a shell I'm afraid I don't
understand mr. Dennis that's right today
I'm going to ask you to stay on here a
Dennis in spite of how you feel to give
us to give this girl to give yourself
even a chance to find out if we're right
you're putting me in a pretty tough spot
mr. Dennis well it may not be as tough
as you think you're making it often
difficult to refuse it would have been
so much easier if you just bawled me out
this is something that has to be handled
reasonably will you give it a try
I think it's only fair to warn you I I
may do all the wrong things you may be
sorry if I stay well every day I'm in
business I'm taking chances I'm willing
to take this one
I'll think about it mr. Dennis I will
say this though it's the first time I've
stopped to think about it at all thank
you
I'm just no hello Larry
the secretary is usually need over here
to join us
there was no mass walkout no one quits a
few girls even tried to help out
resentment turned to curiosity then
curiosity became interest
in time
Mary was no longer the new girl and new
girls no longer meant trouble so we all
settle down again to the difficult
business of making a living